♪ ♪
>> Greg: MATES THE PHRASE YOU
HEAR THESE DAYS FROM DOPES
PRETENDING TO BE SMART.
TOXIC MASCULINITY.
MASCULINITY IS POISON.
FORGET THE GREAT ACHIEVEMENTS
THAT TOOK GREAT RISK ON THE PART
OF MEN AND EVEN RESULTED IN
THEIR DEATHS.
NO, MAN ARE VIOLENT ANIMALS.
BROWN UNIVERSITY OFFERS A COURSE
AIMED AT UNLEARNING TOXIC
MASCULINITY.
WE USED TO CALL IT BASKET
WEAVING 101.
IF YOU ARE WILLING TO GIVE BROWN
50 GRAND FOR THIS, YOU NEED TO
UNLEARN COMMON SENSE TOO.
IT MAKES NO SENSE.
IF MEN ARE SO TOXIC, WHY WOULD
YOU WANT THEM DETOXING ON YOUR
CAMPUS.
UNLEARNING TOXIC MASCULINITY
WILL SOON BE REPLACING WESTERN
CIVICS.
THERE'S NO QUESTION MEN ARE MORE
AGGRESSIVE THAN WOMEN IN SCIENC
SCIENCE.
UNRULY CADS, THAT'S WHAT DADS
AND MOMS USED TO DO BEFORE WE
DECIDED THEY SUCK AND MEN LIVE
SHORTER LIVES.
JUST LOOK AT ME.
MAINLY BECAUSE OF THE RISKS
TAKEN TO ATTRACT AND PROTECT THE
PEOPLE WE LOVE.
IF YOU BELIEVE THIS IS ABOUT
APPRECIATING MEN WHILE TERMING
AWAY THE ROUGH PARTS, YOU GET
YOURSELF.
THIS IS PURE CLASS HATRED BASED
ON STEREOTYPES MEANT TO DEMEAN A
GROUP OF PEOPLE.
IT'S THE BRANDING OF A GENDER BY
ANGRY, BITTER RADICALS.
IT'S ALSO SEXIST.
IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE ME, JUST
CREATE YOUR OWN CLASS FOR BROWN
AND CALL IT UNLEARNING TOXIC
FEMININITY.
HOW LONG DO YOU THINK THAT WILL
LAST?
THEN AGAIN, MAYBE IT'S IN THE
WORKS ALREADY, DESIGNED TO FOCUS
ON THOSE HORRIBLE TOXIC
STAY-AT-HOME MOMS WHO VOTED FOR
TRUMP.
ALL RIGHT, DANA, LET'S SAY YOU
ARE AT BROWN, WHICH I BELIEVE
THE UNIVERSITY.
WOULD YOU DATE A GUY WHO IS
TAKING --
>> Dana: NEVER.
NOT EVEN A QUESTION.
YOU KNOW, WE DO THESE STORIES.
REMEMBER DATING TIPS?
GUTFELD'S DATING TIPS.
NOWHERE ON ANY DATING TIP SHOULD
YOU BE TAKING THIS CLASS.
NOWHERE.
I THINK A BETTER TEST WOULD BE
FOR MEN FROM BROWN TO HAVE TO GO
WORK ON A RANCH.
>> Greg: YES, EXACTLY.
>> Dana: FOR A MONTH.
>> Greg: I AM SAYING THAT AS
SOMEONE WHO COULDN'T WORK ON A
RANCH.
>> Dana: THEY WOULD TAKE YOU.
THEY WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOU COME
VISIT.
>> Greg: IT WOULD END BADLY.
JUAN, ARE YOU FILLED WITH TOXIC
MASCULINITY?
>> Juan: I THINK I COULD USE
THE CLASS.
SEEMS TO ME YOU THAT MALES NEED
TO BE DOMINANT IN THE WAY THAT
WE LOOK AT SEX AND THE
INTERACTION, THINGS HAVE PUZZLED
ME THROUGHOUT MY LIFE.
>> Jesse: EXPLAINED THAT,
JUAN.
>> Juan: I WILL TELL YOU,
JESSE.
YOU ARE A GUY TOO.
THE O.J. SIMPSON CASE, I COULD
NEVER UNDERSTAND WHY A WOMAN
WOULD GO BACK TO A GUY THAT WAS
BEATING HER.
IT'S PUZZLING TO ME.
THEN I HEARD FROM OTHER PEOPLE,
IT'S NOT UNUSUAL.
THAT'S NUTS.
MY NIECE OR PROSECUTOR IN D.C.
AND SHE TELLS ME PEOPLE COME
FROM SOME COUNTRIES AND THEY
WILL SAY THAT'S THE WAY MEN ACT.
MEN HATE WOMEN.
WHAT?
WHERE'S THAT FROM?
>> Jesse: I DON'T KNOW IF O.J.
IS WHAT THEY MEAN WHEN THEY SAY
TOXIC MASCULINITY.
>> Juan: I THINK IT IS.
>> Dana: I THINK YOU SHOULD GO
SURVEYED THE CLASS, JESSE.
>> Jesse: I HAVE A LONG
HISTORY AT BROWN.
WHEN I WAS THERE SHOOTING
"WATTERS' WORLD," A GUY WITH A
SKIRT HECKLED ME.
IT'S BECAUSE I'M SO TOXIC.
I AGREE WITH DANA.
I'VE BEEN UNDER THE ASSUMPTION
THAT WOMEN ARE ATTRACTED TO MEN
WHO ARE MANLY.
THEY MAKE A LOT OF MONEY.
THEY WORK WITH THEIR HANDS AND
SWEEP YOU OFF YOUR FEET, THEY
HOLD THE DOOR FOR YOU.
TAKE CARE OF YOU AND ACT TOUGH.
DON'T CRY.
NEVER SHOW THEIR FEELINGS.
>> Dana: OKAY, YEAH.
THAT'S NOT EXACTLY --
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: DANA, SPEAK UP.
>> Dana: I'M GOING TO LET PAM
SPEAK FOR ME.
>> Greg: PAM, THIS FEELS LIKE
A REEDUCATION CAMP FOR THE EVIL
MALE TO ME.
>> Pam: AS AT GRAD SCHOOL, CAN
YOU IMAGINE LOOKING AT
TRANSCRIPTS SAYING "UNLEASHING
TOXIC MASCULINITY."
WHAT GRADE DID YOU GET?
IF YOU DIDN'T GET A A, YOU'RE IN
BIG TROUBLE.
THIS NEEDS TO BE LEARNED MUCH
YOUNGER IN THE HOME.
IF YOU ARE IN COLLEGE AND YOU
STILL HAVE THESE ISSUES.
>> Greg: BY THE WAY, THE
ISSUES ARE THEY JUST DON'T LIKE
MEN.
>> Dana: AT BROWN, DON'T YOU
THINK GUYS SIGN UP FOR THIS
CLASS THINKING THEY ARE GOING TO
GET A DATE?
>> Jesse: YES!
>> Dana: THEY MIGHT GET A
DATE.
>> Greg: DO YOU WANT TO DATE A
WOMAN INTERESTED IN TAKING TOXIC
MASCULINITY.
>> Dana: WOMEN AT BROWN
PROBABLY WANT THEM TO TAKE THAT
CLASS AND THEY CAN TALK ABOUT
IT.
I DON'T THINK IT WILL LAST.
>> Greg: THE NEW THING IS TO
CALL IT TOXIC.
IF YOU SAID THIS ABOUT WOMEN,
YOU ARE -- YOUR TOXIC
FEMININITY, YOU PROBABLY BE
FIRED.
>> Dana: YOU SHOULD WRITE THAT
ARTICLE TOMORROW.
I THINK IT WOULD BE GREAT.
>> Greg: WHAT ARE THE
SYMPTOMS?
>> Dana: WE TALK ABOUT THEM